après avoir assuré son maintien en
Betclic Elite l'adé à Blois se prépare à
entamer sa deuxième saison dans le top
du basket français les blesois ont
retrouvé le chemin de l'entraînement
début août sans deux joueurs majeurs et
Johnson partie dans d'autres clubs une
préparation technique et tactique à
affiner la DA n'a pas pu s'imposer face
à Cholet ni face à Roanne lors de match
de pré-saison Faustine Luneau
ok est-ce que c'est bon pour
tout l'entraînement a repris depuis près
de deux semaines pour les joueurs de
l'AD à Blois de retour pour une deuxième
saison en ProA les hommes de Michael est
ont déjà joué deux matchs de pré-saison
contre Cholet et Roanne de défaite mais
de justesse les scores de matchs de
poissons
ce qui est important c'est de bien de
bien se préparer je pense que les
joueurs le font en sachant que cette
année on a quasiment renouvelé toute
l'équipe faut laisser du temps parce que
la plupart je leur casse leurs habitudes
voilà bien pas bien c'est pas la
question mais mais donc il faut du temps
pour après les choses et lorsqu'on
réfléchit à des nouvelles choses mais
généralement on n'est pas dans le niveau
d'intensité dont les timings nécessaires
donc il faut laisser le temps au temps
du temps pour apprivoiser cette nouvelle
équipe qui compte cette nouveau joueur
parmi eux Thomas yourtois qui fait son
retour dans le club 5 ans après
confiance pour ma première vraie année
en proie j'ai fait une petite pige à
Strasbourg devant moi mais
sur une saison complète c'est ma
première fois donc je suis là pour
donner le meilleur de moi-même d'autant
que cette année le défi sera un peu plus
dur à relever puisque au terme du
championnat trois équipes au lieu de
deux descendront en Pro B conséquence du
passage de betclick Elite de 18 à 16
clubs à partir de la saison 2024 2025 il
y a une équipe de plus qui est exposée à
la relégation qui est toujours ce qui
fait peur à tout le monde mais nous on
le prend on le prend avec philosophiste
c'est-à-dire que l'essentiel c'est
donner la meilleure version de ce qu'on
peut être la pression négative elle
amène rarement de bonnes choses
jouera son premier match de la saison à
domicile face à Gravelines Dunkerque et
qui rejoint de cette année par l'ancien
meneur Blaisois Thomas Cornelli on est
en coéquipier et amis dans la vie c'est
c'est ça va être ça va être drôle de se
rejouer ici pour nous ça va pas changer
normalement de choses je pense que plus
pour lui ça va être va devoir gérer les
émotions du retour en attendant ce face
à face de début de championnat la baie
rera Le Mans ce vendredi puis Cholet à
nouveau samedi